consumer electronic show mieux connu
sous l'acronyme crs est le plus grand
salon techno de l'année imaginer écart
superficie ces cinq fois le palais des
congrès de montréal va s'ouvrir à las
vegas le 8 janvier quelles nouveautés
techniques seront en cédant au cours des
prochaines de la prochaine année on va
parler avec pascal forget chroniqueur à
l'émission planète techno qui a déjà
bouclé ses valises ou pas - les valises
sont en train de se fermer aujourd'hui
je décode de même atteint à peu près en
ce moment j'ai assez à quand la veille
d'un marathon sibilité où c'est noël
après noël
le 3 mai parce que c'est là que les
grosses compagnies magazine tous leurs
produits techno pour l'année c'est là
que vous allez magasiner
tout ce que vous allez nous raconter au
cours des prochaines années après m'être
techno dites-nous sur quelles tendances
clés 2019
allez vous braquez en fèves aux
projecteurs c'est très drôle parce que
le civis avant c'était l'endroit où les
grosses compagnies annoncé leurs grosses
nouveautés ont dévoilé le vhs ont
dévoilé les motifs n'ont pas joué je
sais mais ça fait cinquante deux ans que
ça existe
donc on dévoilait le vhs ont dévoilé le
dvd le blu ray le 4 cores on mettait en
valeur
maintenant l'accent est mis sur les plus
petites entreprises s'est rendu le plus
gros salon de start up au monde
d'entreprises en démarrage
il ya 155 pays deux des compagnies de
155 pays qui sont présentes et qui vont
dévoiler des petites d'innovation des
choses qui vont les petits produits pas
nécessairement des gros truc
révolutionnaire dévoilé avec fanfares
mais les petits produits donc on va
passer beaucoup de temps là il ya 1200
stop juste qu'en terme de cantine 1200
petites compagnies qui vont à présent
donc je mange ça peut être des gardiens
pour des appareils qui se couple à
d'autres à 6 ans a parlé pas leur
rapport les poils c'est tout le monde me
demande qu'est ce qui a encore annoncé à
pour les polos ils font leurs événements
parce que l'inconvénient c'est qu'il ya
tellement de noms ce que les grosses
compagnies souvent maintenant font plus
leur conférence avant ou après pour
avoir l'intérêt des choses qu'on vend
les grosses tendances entre autres il la
guerre vous parlez d'objets connectés
la guerre des assistants personnels vos
coups syrie alex alexis tanghe on veut
pas entrer chez soi puis parler à trois
personnes
allumer les lumières avec un assistant
fermer les rideaux avec la outre on veut
que ce soit même donc on va regarder les
compagnies en à toronto c'est ce qu' on
veut aussi le produit qu'on n'achète
qu'on se procure est compatible avec les
stands notre choix non ce soir est une
des guerres qu'on veut voir pendant le
cs l'autre chose la téléphonie 5g en
vaut beaucoup ont abandonné ces
nouvelles générations de téléphonie
cellulaire qui est beaucoup plus rapide
beaucoup plus performante
ça permet d'avoir un modem à la maison
que peu de films qui est plus rapide que
sa création du rassemblement à la maison
et ses cellulaires donc on peut déplacer
comme on veut on peut avoir son à sa
voiture on peut connecter des objets
plus besoin de configurer la fin avec la
5g
on pourra voir des modems avec fils
commence à disparaître exactement
les gens vont se concentrer un peu plus
sur cette mobilité c'est sophie tous les
objets bon port de être connectés et on
n'a pas besoin de chercher quand on
achète un produit normalement le
configure on installe les numéros eye-fi
on cherche le mot de passe et tout donc
on va on pour être aimé notre modèle
chez honoré une sélection plus rapide
que pour bientôt
ça s'en vient l'infrastructure
s'installe en ce moment mais les
compagnies dans cette année vont
commencer à dévoiler les premiers
appareils qui sont compatibles appareils
concret l'autre chose qu'on va voir
revoir des nouveautés comme le téléphone
pliants on en rêve tous on a des gros
téléphone et jean vilain petit téléphone
un téléphone dont l'écran se plie
on va en voir un ça me semble devrait en
annoncer en touche du bois ou encore
l'annoncé pendant ces cinquante convives
un petit téléphone mais quand on veut
une tablette ont pu déployer
on revoit des trucs comme ça et des
produits peut-être plus étrange
également mais un truc dont j'ai gibert
de voir ça c'est un protecteur buccal
intelligent on se dit on est rendu à
connecter tous là un protecteur buccal
pourquoi mais on peut imaginer que s'il
ya des capteurs à l'intérieur ça
permettrait de dépister ou de prévenir
les commotions cérébrales
on pourrait voir avec le protecteur
buccal de la personne si un impact trop
grand dans les événements sportifs et je
trouve ça intéressant parce que la
grosse tendance évidemment c'est tout
est connecté
il fait découvrir dentiste pourraient
avoir accès à des données par rapport à
fossiles
c'est ça la nuit
ces livres sont un peu perdus d'un
pendant son année a conclu avec le
protecteur alors vous partez demain pour
la zec demain le jeune celle venant avec
marie audrey houle l'équipe dans de
l'équipe de planète techno on va avoir
deux émissions la première et les 18
janvier à 19 heures
ces temps de suivre sur les médias
sociaux que ce qu'on veut mettre du
contenu certainement du bonus donc vous
allez allez vraiment faire le plein
d'idées là bas et on vous suit en
terminant tact une dernière chose que
vous aller surveiller en 2019 sur la
côte est facturée 19 les véhicules
autonomes évidemment nous avons appuyé
le fait que quand on conduit plus qu'est
ce qu'on va faire une compagnie
québécoise qui va être la baule et
d'artec qui défait des capteurs pour
détecter les obstacles des outils très
intéressants mais chaque fois que ça
soulève également son lot de questions
et de réflexion sociale et y avoir sur
l'apparition de ces technologies led à
nos vies merci beaucoup parce que son
jab bon voyage lire ces de las vegas on
vous regarde la planète techno